ingère vraiment les critères et
s'assoupir par jean pascal on va
profiter de votre présence fait un appel
solennel le caméra et jazz air brush
ballon guillaume roux qui subit là bas
donc relier la caméra fait un appel
solennel à 6,8 alliés concernant
l'ouverture merde des candidatures elles
me répondent toujours pas sylvie écoute
même si on a quelques différences rire
ravis de partager un café avec toi donc
j'attends que si un jour tu veux me
connaître je serai ravi de partager un
café avec toi et surtout voilà que ça
bouge pour les miss aussi peut-être pour
ma collègue juste à ma gauche qui est
formidable donc voilà essayons de tous
[Applaudissements]
ils me l'ont dit c'est d'avoir votre
avis sur les dangers juste un appel
aussi à faire à sylvie comme vous avez
apparemment du mal à trouver des miss
qui n'ont pas posé nue je peux le
garantir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]